foreign
you're not just Invincible you're also
like earth's best food cooking man
pretty impressive what oh no I I just
worked here I don't actually make the
food
um next time also constructive criticism
do not put these green things in here
these are gross
yeah
um hey so did you ever find a Wrath
yeah of course I found it uh very very
quickly very easily yellow Skies purple
grass and get this they have Burgers
there too just like these who would have
guessed huh you never found it right no
nope not even close I hope they're okay
I think about them quite a bit honestly
but uh how about you what have you been
up to it's been a while I think everyone
agrees it's been like a little
ridiculous how long it's been hey I've
been busy doing what
well I've been busy
riding designing a storyboarding voice
acting e-posing in between cleaning up
color slapping copying the whole thing
and all that for you know roughly
thousands of shots so it's kind of a lot
sure yeah although like 90 of that if
I'm being honest sounds completely made
up but the real question is when are you
going back out there the world needs
more Invincible uh it's coming okay hey
yeah I know but like a specific date
would be nice oh my okay fine the world
will get more Invincible in uh late
2023. all right hope
oh late
perfect sure
so 2023 is that like one of your years
you know our planets they all have
different systems of keeping track of
time like they go around their stars at
different speeds but the way you said
that number makes it sound soon is that
soon I really want it to be soon